[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
it's a new year 2022 and another 12
months ahead of us of new games and a
scary amount of re-releases vying for
your cash and attention all year round
january is renowned for being the
slowest month in the video game industry
yet there are a handful of games worth
your time like usual i've found a few
free experiences to tide you over and a
dumb question at the end of the video
like always let's do this
first we have tom clancy's rainbow six
extraction extraction is firmly based in
the play style of rainbow six siege the
operators the weapons the same slow
pacing and thought goes into everything
but that's where the similarities end as
extraction is not about slaying other
real world players it's a co-op shooter
going up against ai-controlled aliens
your mission is to infiltrate an enemy
stronghold collect the thing the
macguffin and extract again if you were
playing siege back in 2018 you've
technically already tried extraction the
ltm outbreak was the birth of this idea
and it spawned an entire standalone game
ubisoft know this is going to be a tough
sell so here's a cool little extra when
one player buys the game they can invite
two other players to play for free for
two whole weeks allowing friends to try
a game without limits is a great way to
attract more people it's clear that
cooperation and teamwork are integral
playing this game alone just doesn't
work so start talking to your squad
right away see if it's a game for them
from that point it's your choice how you
going breach and clear or stealth the
entire mission it's also been confirmed
that post launch content is coming thick
and fast and right away there is expert
level content end game content added
each week it changes as you climb up the
pro ranks online rainbow six extraction
released on january 20th on playstation
xbox pc and stadia which is still a
thing in 2022
[Music]
next we have a couple of playstation
exclusives which have now come to pc and
i couldn't be happier as of january 14th
pc players can see what all the fuss is
about with god of war the playstation 4
swan song we fill the boots of dad of
boy as they fulfill his mother's dying
wish the journey is emotional and the
bond is created between the two and you
can also throw an axe and you can summon
it back like a big angry bald thor
speaking of thor kratos is no longer in
the greek pantheon and has now ventured
into the nordic world it's almost four
years since the story was told and it
won't look any better than on pc a good
pc that is unlocked frame rates and true
4k are here and available for people
with more money than sense it's gonna
look beautiful with playstation offering
their games up to the pc audience it
should see more of us getting excited
for the next god of war game ragnarok
coming later in 2022
the other playstation pc release is
uncharted legacy of thieves collection
releasing on january 28th on ps5 and pc
at the same time this includes the
sublime uncharted 4 and the criminally
underrated lost legacy a third person
action adventure with tons of cover
shooting here's a great touch if you own
either of those games on ps4 you'll be
able to upgrade to both of them on ps5
for 10
the pricing is kind of weird so here's
the info on screen if you prefer to read
it yourself just pause the video hang on
what's that people who have the ps plus
version of the game cannot upgrade and
the multiplayer portion has been
stripped from the games too
come on sony the playstation 5 upgrade
will support full 4k at 30 frames per
second and if you have a monitor capable
of seeing it 120 frames per second at
1080p which is smooth as silk so play
nathan drake's final adventure one last
time and see where the story is likely
going in years to come
let's do some free stuff there's quite a
lot to go through first up is a
monumentous occasion the juggernaut of
the battle royal family has finally gone
free to play as of january 12th
playerunknown's battleground is free on
playstation xbox and pc after 70 plus
million copies have been sold it's
finally time to give it away for free if
you've been living under a rock you
should know that pubg is arguably the
game which made battle royale into the
world dominating game it is today
fortnite warzone and apex legends all
call this game daddy but like most
daddies the kids have surpassed them 100
players parachute onto an island and
scavenge for weapons and murderize each
other and to be the sole survivor if
this doesn't look like something for you
i still beg you to try it at least it's
like visiting your grandparents at
christmas they can still teach you a
thing or two pubg goes free to play
everywhere on january 12th
[Music]
gamers on ps5 and xbox series can also
play the matrix awakens experience right
now we can't really call this a game
it's more of a showcase for the future
of epic games unreal engine graphically
though this demo is mind-blowing the
detail and filmic aesthetic is a wow
moment this is probably the closest
you'll ever get to feeling like you're
in a movie there's a car chase and
there's tons of easter eggs to find
after the main mission is over it won't
last you a long time but it will open
your mind to the future of what video
games will look like in years to come oh
fortnight llama oh there are a few more
free things you should know about the
ps5 version of rec room has been
released i have no idea why but it's a
thing so if you like 3d shenanigans with
friends in rec room the ps5 has its own
standalone version which runs way
quicker is quite impressive and if
you're a ps plus subscriber and added
final fantasy 7 remake to your library
last year you should know that you now
have the ps5 version already added to
your library completely for free pretty
good move if you ask me although it did
take a bit longer than it should be sure
to check back on wednesday and we'll go
through the new january ps plus games by
the way until then i think that's the
end of the free stuff you can get this
month i'll see you next month
and finally a small hello to an indie
game which is crazy addictive win
jammers 2. the first game was released
back in 1994
and was very simple throw a disc past
your opponent to score that's that's
really it the subtlety comes via
tactical throws and bending the disc
into new positions expect wind jammers
too to be super cheap and likely on ps
plus or games with gold soon after all
the sprites have been hand drawn and
animated giving windjammers 2 a retro
feel which is quite appealing to an old
fart like me so there we have it not
much this month but 7 new releases to
tide you over in january 2022 any take
your fancy if you're still here let's
let's bond a little i want to know what
is the greatest game you've ever played
i look forward to arguing with you in
the comments i'm adam you're awesome
i'll see you next time
hey
[Music]